I can't believe that waxing the floors
and we're all stuck in here I've never
seen them do this before I do it once a
month
and night shift I know
Florida oh I don't listen to so much
stuff you all say well frankly I pitied
a lot of you you look out there and see
a problem I look out there and see an
opportunity I'm gonna slide on that
slippery floor all the way from Holt's
office to the elevator you're gonna do
the fbp that's right Rosa I'm doing the
full bullpen
[Music]
[Music]
the world
[Music]
the full Bullpen hey Gina you got that
file I needed Captain hold the sign
[Music]
Gina hasn't taken her eyes off her phone
in two hours first person to make her
look up wins the pot I'm in bet which
improves someone's manners double score
sorry guys I got this in the bag I used
to have to distract her from my phone
all the time when we were smooshing
booties oh yeah
hey girl
catch you later mid morning dance party
is dancing even better than normal
oh my god did you hear that George W
Bush died who died
Gina may never look at another real
human being again she's unbeatable I
don't know about that
Jeffords are you kidding me changed my
relationship status to It's Complicated
Pony up y'all
oh
it's my wife hey baby
no no no no it was a mistake my thumb
slipped it
I have to go home so again your Alibi is
a mysterious stranger handed you the gun
made you put your prince on it robbed
the store and then hid the gun in your
underpants Well yeah if you say it like
that it don't sound believable oh hey
Captain did you get my report on the
Finley murder oh yeah I looked it over
nice work good thanks Dad
why is everyone staring at me you just
called Captain hold dad he said thanks
Dad what no I didn't I said thanks man
do you see me as a father figure Peralta
no if anything I see you is a bother
figure because you're always bothering
me hey show your father some respect I
didn't call him Dad no no no no Jacob I
take it as a compliment it's not a big
deal I called Vivian mom once and she's
my fiance guys jump on that Boyle has
psychosexual issues old news but you
calling Hulk daddy daddy is not on the
table here but you did call him dead
dude you shut up you've done nothing but
lie since you got here all right all
right I was lying about the holdup but
the dad thing that happened
he admitted that his Alibi was a lie it
was a trap all part of my crazy devious
plan I believe you thank you son
you want to talk about it later over a
give him a catch
I'd like that
ladies and gentlemen prepare to start
clapping because I just made a major
drug bust talking about four kilos of
cocaine 200 000 cash and
my new partner a tarantula I call him
Jake Jr AKA Spidey cloom AKA Mrs doubt
spider AKA Joe Biden AKA tarantula
Bassett AKA spy Dermot Mulroney AKA
tarantulina Jolie what no Charles have
you seen the spider that's a terrible
name sorry why do you have that thing
because they were gonna throw him away
but I couldn't let them do that to my
furry little dog it's actually really
scary up close it's horrifying from
everywhere Terry hates Creepy Crawlers
seriously I'm not going to your
apartment if that thing is there all
right fine then he'll just live here and
help me solve crimes get used to him
everyone because me and this spider are
Partners For Life he's gone I left the
cage unlocked and he's gone
I'm good I'm out of here he couldn't
have gone far unless he can fly can
tarantulas fly Jake you better find that
spider and I'm not coming back here
until you do
massage
I think I found it
[Music]
why are you looking at me like that
it's on my head
monsters and feast your eyes on what I
hold in this hand the future of movement
a hoverboard I don't understand those
things it's walking really so hard for
you oh Ames walking's a nightmare yeah
Amy now friends
eat my space dust
okay a little harder to control than I
thought okay there we go I think I'm
getting the hang of it no I'm not oh
I'm all right
I'm doing it
I'm doing it you got this no I do not
got this Terry don't let go of me the
future of movement is now hey
you guys see the dude I brought in today
the drug dealer 81 years old I think
it's the oldest collar of my entire
career I once arrested a 96 year old for
flashing I was terrified he'd die in my
backseat or Flash me my oldest collar
was 78 but the PCP made her fight like
she was 20. what about two 50 year old
twins does that count as 100 year old no
good no you talking all this bags
68. that's not that old yeah but I was
only 20 20. were you even a cop then no
man it was before I got into the academy
Charles isn't talking about his oldest
arrest
I say yes I am yeah oldest arrest 68
like I said God you had sex with a 68
year old when you were in your 20s you
know how it is when you have a chance to
bet an older woman no that is not an
older woman that's an old woman that's
someone's grandma
she was actually that's how I met her
grandson Marvin don't knock it to you
she had a replacement hit with some
serious torque I was like having sex
with a Transformer that is no one's
fantasy aunt
ant ant and God they're everywhere are
we sure that we've cleaned up all the
food and crumbs
why is everyone looking at us we're the
ones who eat up for the crumbs yeah
we're the solution well there are no
ants on my desk because I sanitize it
daily what do you call that those are
Jordan
this is an invasion they're in my yogurt
now it's personal all right that's it we
have gotta fight back this is our planet
just use Boyle's cologne it's repulsive
to everything not cool you're going to
Penn Station to buy me a new one the ant
infestation it's bad they bite now sir I
think they're just trying to avoid the
cold weather
we should freeze them out
the plane is working Captain yes we won
oh my God
they're in the coats
wait for it wait for it 901 Amy Santiago
is officially late for the first time
ever
all right let's do this who's got
theories uh alarm didn't go up all three
alarms all with battery backup come on
who wants to take this seriously she was
taken in her sleep that's what I'm
talking about super dark boil but way
more plausible than the Sarge's idiotic
alarm clock Theory I bet she tucked
herself into bed too tight and got stuck
maybe she fell into another dimension
where she's interesting it's 9 A.M
why is no one working Amy Santiago is a
few minutes late and we're all trying to
guess why I like to play
I'd say she's in line at the bank
this is fun it is fun but you're all
wrong she clearly slipped through a
Subway grade and is having terrible sex
with a mole man
there she is Amy where have you been
we've been worried sick do you care to
explain yourself I'm just 70 seconds
late it's not a big deal don't worry
about it Santiago you will tell us and
you will tell us now
there's a problem at the bank
bottles
oil
what are you bottles boil Bullpen
bowling behold Brooklyn buddies boil
Bullpen bottle bowling beautiful be
brave bro be brave
ah